Film Courage: We have this quote here
and this is from a forward in your book
and this is by Jay Roach and I don't
know if you want to read part of it
and we've only fit a portion of it on the
board here we have the rest of it here.
Kelly Edwards, Staff Writer, Author,
Producer: Sure, most development execs
producers and even assistants you encounter
along the way are solid story crafters and
could directly or indirectly become your
collaborators and co-creators if you would.”
Film Courage: dot dot dot “just engage with
them enthusiastically as teammates rather than
defensively as critics and saboteurs.” Where
does your mind go when you hear that quote?
Kelly: Well what immediately
pops to mind is how many
stories I know of people who found a
property or found a script or found
a writer and latched on and like a dog with a
bone forced that thing into existence right so
I could think of you think about Gina
Bailey and with Game of Thrones or
I don't know I don't know I feel like a
lot of things that I've done where you find
somebody and you just go I'm so excited
about this writer let's figure it out
there's a lot of stories I think that you can
you can pull out of that HBO alone like I said
I'm listening to this book right now and it's just
like David Levine and True Detective like there's
Franny [Francesca] Orsi in and how she really
took I don't know she she took my brilliant
friend and just it was her baby from start to
finish now that wasn't on anybody's radar so
what a what a miracle that that she was able
to create something along with the team that
she had assembled and the writer and and all
of that into something that's so beautiful so
you have to remember that for every failed
project there's probably another equally
passionate executive who is putting together
something else and sometimes sometimes that
thing that first thing isn't the thing sometimes
it's the second thing sometimes it's the third
thing sometimes you just have to keep going until
you find the right collaborator or you find that
right idea and it's the right time there's so many
again so many pieces of why something works at a
particular time and why something might just miss
the mark but we are all part of the same ecosystem
the executives the person who who essentially
takes that piece of work that writer
nurtures that writer hopefully in the right way
and then gives that that projects the the the
place to flourish into and to grow and I think
that no one gets into being an executive with
terrible intentions we don't it's a lot of work
so we don't go into it thinking I'm going to go
smash people's dreams and ruin their careers you
go in thinking you can help you go in thinking
oh I love this writer so much I love this idea
so much let me see how I can help it navigate
through the gauntlet of everything that it
needs to in order to get to the finish line
and again I think that the when it when
things really hit they're usually surprise
I think sometimes you can see things coming I
think when we all saw the pilot of er we knew
it was groundbreaking or CSI the first one was
groundbreaking or there are some pieces that just
pop out Breaking Bad they just think that that
just sort of automatically blow your your hair
back but sometimes things like Seinfeld that take
time to nurture and then become huge and hit and
hit really well and you just don't know you just
have to believe in love in the the process and the
the creators and and you have to love
story we just we get into it because
we love story we we are the same people that
look I'm the perfect example I'm both writer
and executive and they had the ability to
to to do both and now I'm able to do both
but I was the same person who watched the 3:30 ABC
movie every single day and watched Fred Astaire
and Ginger Rogers and Annette [Funicello] and
Frankie [Avalon] and I wanted to be involved in
that storytelling and we all read a ton of books
and we all do our homework and so our intentions
are always good we don't always execute them
well and we sometimes do have to grow up so I
think back on the the notes that I gave when
I was young they would be so different today
and I desperately feel like I want to apologize to
every writer I gave notes to when I was too young
to know how it really really works so sometimes
we are not quite as skilled as we want to be
and we need to do growing up just like a writer
needs to evolve just like the whole process needs
to evolve so but I think that he's absolutely
right in that we're all part of the same
big idea which is we all want to see
stories created and some of us just
do it on different sides of the of the pro
of the process but we are all collaborators
sure but then when someone looks at it in a
defensive light is it because you had said
earlier there's so much going on behind the scenes
that we don't always know with the network and and
whether it's advertisers or or notes that the
fans are giving back different things and so is
the writer privy to all that not always I think
there are a lot of there are a lot of meetings
that happen and there's then there's sometimes
there's things that that you hold back or you
don't want to I mean there's plenty of stories
about I have tons of stories about projects that
you'd be shocked about all this the steps and
the things and how many times it might have
fallen apart is that important for the creator to
know absolutely not would it hurt that person's
feelings absolutely if they knew exactly what was
happening in those rooms it would be devastating
so sometimes that not knowing is not a bad thing
sometimes that's why people feel like sometimes
executives are too close to the chest and because
things are they change the snap of a finger
so let's just say you've we've got a project
it looks like it's going forward but I can't
necessarily tell you for for sure it's going
forward because I don't know they might change
they might change the whole direction the minute
before I if I pull the trigger too fast and then
they decided not to do something then you've then
I've blown that conversation you've already gotten
your hopes up so there's a reason sometimes why
they feel really cagey because they don't know
or they haven't been given the authorization to
pull the trigger and a perfect example of that is
I can't say it's perfect but so Eunetta Boone
who passed away had done a show a pilot called
one-on-one for us and and yet we didn't see it on
air until a year after so she she was waiting for
the pickup the year before she was at the party
she was waiting for that note for the for we
were in New York and she was waiting for the the
notice that she was going to be on stage that next
day I'm pretty sure that that's how it went and
we ended up at the last minute not picking that
show up so that was devastating enough but imagine
if we had already said you're on stage and then we
told her two seconds before she wasn't gonna
be on stage now the good news is we loved it
so much we picked it up the next year and the
show was off the races in this amazing show
but sometimes we don't have all the information
and then that comes across as cagey deceitful
they're not sharing why are they doing this they
just don't know so it's it's a such a terrible
little swirl of silence that sometimes can
permeate and that can feel that the that the world
is against you it feels like the execs are against
you but then what you don't see is the same exacts
fighting for a project fighting for the life of
something I had to fight to get I wasn't allowed
to pick up Malcolm in the Middle at UPN but I
fought to get it released in a time when there
was a strict policy that said we do not release
projects so they can go on other networks and I
said we need to this needs to exist somewhere now
you don't see that in books you don't see that in
I think I might have written put in my book but
there you don't you don't hear those stories about
how people do champion and try to nurture and
try to foster and try to help why would there
why would there be execs in the room fighting
against it so then why is one team want it
and one team doesn't well things things like
scheduling come into it so let's just say at
a network you've got you've got a huge board when
we were doing our programming for for UPN or even
for Fox they have these gigantic boards and on
these boards there's their strips so on one side
it's like the the time slot and then the network
or either way time slot in the network and then
each little strip it's a magnetized strip has
the name of the show that the pilot that was just
produced and so what we're doing is we're hedging
our bets and we're trying to think well if CBS
has all procedurals and we're trying to counter
program with all comedies what's the best comedy
that goes up against the series, procedural the
drama family drama on NBC the ABC's got comedies
but they're buddy comedies let's go with a family
comedy or let's go with a drama so we are trying
to figure out our schedule based on what other
people are doing so at the time that we're doing
this this has been again right up right before up
fronts so people haven't announced their schedules
when they get announced is when everybody
knows specifically when things are happening
so we are trying to counter program and figure
out well what's our best slate that's going to do
well against the others because we don't want as a
UPN or a or a fox or even if you're thinking these
days with with some of the other networks they
don't want the same show to compete against the
same show right they don't want a black female
comedy up against another black female comedy
or cannibalize your audience so we're trying to
find the spaces where those audiences are are not
being served someplace else that's why sometimes
things move forward or don't move forward that's
why somebody might be fighting for for or against
maybe they don't love that show or they don't love
that star or they don't think that it's going
to do well on for that particular demographic
or whatever there's so many different reasons
again those are that's making the sausage that's
the whole other thing that's that's underneath
that people don't always hear about do we have
the right audience are people showing up to us for
this or can they get this better someplace else.